most of you have thought okay I've got
all this information it'll be useful for
me to plot this on and see what this is
going to look like and how it's going to
behave so here's my graph of population
against time right if by the way it
bears mentioning about what we're
looking at here while we try to
understand is not just exponential
growth or decay but growth indicate
situations with constraints the way that
this is often referred to in the
syllabus documents in the programs is
it's called modified growth and decay
you'll see why shortly okay now what
does it look like what data points do
you have
well you've got a starting point you've
got a point of time here and then you
have this sort of limiting behavior
right so I'm going to try that account
for all those on this graph by putting a
nice sort of scale like this two four
six eight ten we start with a population
of 2000 right then we're going to tend
toward this population of 10,000 that's
where I'm going toward but remember we
said the whole idea of this number is
that it's a constraint it's saying
you're never gonna get there you're
gonna try and get close it only increase
that's what populations do assuming you
know mortality rates aren't that bad but
it's it's not going to be able to reach
there because that's the limit of the
environment okay so we're getting this
kind of behavior and then we have a
point in time this is true then 6k would
be young hey so you pick and that
represents what's happened after three
years okay great now that's what you've
got from there I mean the first question
was can we take that and express this
algebraically well what are we actually
looking at right and once we have some
how's your weekend then beneath you
later and we can move on from there okay
well you've got some pieces to choose
from right you've got a typical
exponential growth situation and you
have a typical exponential decay
situation now clearly it does not match
either of those okay but we need to
think about well which of it is it
closer to and how can I sort of modify
of these to get to approximate something
like this so I could model it okay now I
wonder part of the problem is you don't
you've got growth happening right you've
got growth happening but it's not
exponential growth because exponential
growth just sort of skyrockets it goes
often we clearly see that's not
happening right so you have growth which
looks like this but you have growth that
is slowing down it kind of looks like
this right so being that I want some of
these characteristic so I'm gonna see
how I can take advantage of those to
express something like this so for
instance if I want something slowing
down I've gotta build off this but I
what's it to be growing not decaying
right so logical detail at least
algebraically what I can do is take that
DK graph and turn it upside down that
would give me a growth situation that's
slowing down wouldn't it so if I want to
graph like this okay below the axis
because I've vertically 50 flipped
everything right
what would the equation of something
like this what would it look like it'll
be this one would be negative AE to that
negative KT right you've got the
negative up of the power which makes you
slow down and then you've got this
negative out the front which is what
makes it change it from a decreasing
function to an increasing function okay
that's good that's better
you've got at least the same kind of
shape behavior going on but I assume we
do not want negative populations right
so how do I further modify this in order
to get something close up I need a
vertical shift don't I so in order to
move this asymptote upward right and
then have the same kind of behavior
right obviously I'm going to need to
introduce so clods that have some kind
something like this right if I if I take
this and I add some constant like see
right now I've got this shape
yeah I've got this okay so this is good
right so I have some idea of what I
think this might be I think it's
something like this now I need to know
what these pieces are okay
how am I gonna work out what these are
well a reasonable guess because when we
looked at these right a came from the
initial condition and that's why it's
also often called pain naught right at
time zero that's what's happening okay
the initial condition we provided is mm
mm right so a reasonable guess might be
sticky in a equals mm suppose okay
because that's what it was before right
the initial condition what happens when
you get population equals C minus mm e
to the minus KT right so then you say
well at time zero time 0 this thing e to
the minus KT becomes it becomes 1 right
1 okay so therefore the population study
will see - mm right but we already said
that we started mm should be that are
you following so far so this suggests
based off of this guess right suppose
this suggests that see that number at
the front that person is four thousand
four thousand so going from this guess
we're getting this kind of equation P is
a function of time gives us this this
okay now does it seem like a reasonable
guess does it does it bear a resemblance
to the data we got and you've got a
problem
can I know who's seen the problem you
can see it
you know when I came to this right I
said to move it upwards
I should add some constant C on this
graph way with CB I've moved it up the
asymptotes used to be at zero if I've
moved it up C units the asymptotes
should now be at C right
whoa-ohh-ohh at C equals 4,000 that
means that well according to this
equation I'm tending toward 4,000 but
I'm not
it doesn't match the data right so it
turns out this was a bad way to go so
thinking about this is why it's
wonderful a great indicator right you
cannot make the same assumptions about a
that you did before because we have
changed what's going on here right so
it's not just gonna simply follow the
same nice and simple rules we had
earlier okay so therefore let's think
about this a better way because there
was a bad idea to suppose that let's
suppose something else how else could we
approach this what might be a better
point to start with let's start by
working out C first okay so we're going
to think about the limit as time
approaches infinity right of the
population okay we know what that limit
is we set it over here it's 10,000 right
but what would it be equal to in terms
of this this here right well you're
gonna have a sea front - now what
happens here what does this what does
this do as T approaches infinity well
you've got this is actually on the
denominator isn't it because there's a
negative there okay so the denominator
is growing it's skyrocketing so this
thing actually just vanishes it goes
away but like we just said we know what
this limit is is 10,000 okay there you
go actually that makes a lot of sense
when you think about how that behaves
and how we try make some guess what
right so therefore now I've got some
information which I actually can match
up against what I've got now I should go
and work out
okay so I can stick in my initial
condition Matt right there's my initial
population
okay so let's stick this guy in a 2,000
10,000 now we already said what happens
when time equals zero e to the minus KT
is just 1 right so this becomes a yeah
if I can still do my arithmetic back
that's right okay great I've got P as a
function of time how do you eliminate C
and a looks like this there's one last
constant to deal with isn't there what's
the what's left any K which corresponds
to how fast this is growing so therefore
which piece of information should I use
it should be this one right do you see
how this if I changed this that would
change you know is this steeper or is it
shallower all those kinds of things all
I've accounted for is where I start and
where I'm going to end
I haven't accounted for that quickly or
slowly I get there okay that's why it's
this piece of information that will give
me K and other information and care okay
so let's just pop that in it really ends
up just being a bit of algebra right
when T equals three population is 6,000
so we're going to get a new what's this
young so 6,000 what's it going to be it
should be minus 3k yeah okay cuz there's
my client just rearranged a little bit
let's see how much we can doing this
that's going to be negative 4,000
3k so you divide three you're gonna get
a half over there
now what take logs right so now I'm okay
now I could of course stick that minus
sign in here to make it a lot - that'd
be nice and simple but why we've looked
at this before why why should I even
bother because I already have a minus
sign up in there so they're gonna cancel
anyway so finally I have my population
right as a function of time and no other
things in the way okay let's see get rid
of that negative there you go
take a breath so now it's tricky wasn't
it because of this modified situation
you had to think about your clusters
carefully there's three of them and
you've gotta work them out in a certain
order based on the information that
you're provided